hello everybody and welcome to part 6 of
amnesia the Dark Descent all right I
ain't scared of nobody I'm just gonna
come in here barge on in take everyone
down a couple pegs scary
you know scare me yes right they all ran
away after that was coming so tough
throw barrel
looks like a whole lot of nothing yeah
don't scare me I'm scared running the
opposite direction
new
all right whatever
comes around I'll punch him in his face
I'll see a monster
it's the music trying to be dramatic
young music is the attention
once again just cuz I'm sprinting for
the exit doesn't mean I'm scared cuz
you're scared back home hey nothin no
monsters
oh right ah
don't forget your bag Daniel knew Daniel
but her shame in using a parasol in the
desert
yes serious as it happens it's
imperative to your survival no it's not
it looks ridiculous yes the shade will
perk and I know it's short
going to get those three middle-school
girls from that commercial to come
laughing
open yard ah you have an ascending would
it take us to the inner sanctum it will
definitely take care of the vertical
part of our journey so you have written
an elevator before yes the Colosseum a
Regents Park as well it takes you to the
gallery where you can view the panorama
the panorama this ride might be a little
longer and in the other direction so
sideways ah of course it's not working
oh yeah the rod for part Trinity faced
of course
because why would I want to make any
progress in this game
up for the
study Osler
something said something about the study
the other parts in here
along with some monsters who need their
face punched by me and my fists
well that was a long loading time all
right
would have got it who's there huh
tinderbox come on give it sea chest
Khmer tender box you can hold more than
that chest why didn't you have more even
the Sun was here give me oil ah ha who's
there no one nope no D is all god that's
a lot huh helliya dramas weirdest cook
looses Mithraic olds dot too
chamber in the woods nearby ravine I
think this guy was raped in woods
continued my escape yes he definitely
was pain echo cry of pain yep oh that's
sad
oh boy grassy field outside Genoa Howlin
cry altstadt Agrippa who the heck is
Heimlich cornelius agrippa yeah what up
he's probably ah ah shut up doggy doggy
who's there Oh rabbit yeah dog head I'm
not touching ah fear and pain and go
genus burst of energy trying to harvest
energy from dying things that sounds
familiar
what's in here bird Freebird Freebird oh
you're dead okay nobody who's there
good you are good yeah back off
uh-oh
skulls ooh oh whoa what a [ __ ] is that
what is it
oh my god uh
only one look at it oh oh oh God
oh it's so creepy Oh here you guys look
at it I'm gonna close my eyes
aha now I can't see it and you guys are
all looking at it
haha okay ha whoo yeah great testily
blocked
right circle weakness
oh where my brute strength comes in oh
oh yeah ha I'm so strong ha ha who did
the box oh this is where I can end my
journey I bet if I want to just leap off
here I have to deal with this [ __ ]
anymore where's that cobwebs oh oh that
goop
oh it's in the trees why is it in the
trees oh I'm cool why the pigs here
ha ha
um Agrippa
Agrippa guy that's a guy huh
Agrippa betrayed someone Daniel may be
Pope rod flow second rod all right and
uh eight up oh this movie board up eight
down eight gotcha
Trinity for phase complete steam flow
cycle gotcha
okay oil yep
rubble chest Gavin
Okabe oh yeah ah Oh Ben oh there we go
oh right to tinderboxes
ah
Daniel why are you scared of a tree
there are a lot of real things to be
scared about your day
sprinting to the exit for efficiency I
don't show you all to get bogged down in
boring details needs to be exciting
interesting to watch Oh blood Oh take a
nap in here
good cuz I'm so tired
oh no ha ha ha ha
would who want to who's German Daniel is
it really July Journal 1815 now here's
your journal I received a letter today
from the Algerian governor's office
disclosing the fate of Herbert's
expedition about a week after my
departure her Abdullah one of the men
travelling with us Dullahan from the
desert he was badly injured as if maimed
by a lion it wasn't the man rambled
deliriously about the expedition being
attacked by something horrible which
wasn't a large quickly dispatched a
search party to look for the expedition
after searching for days they found the
camp abandoned without any trace of
Herbert or his men those guys reading
tomorrow yeah I'll retrieve the things
they recovered ah
right here uh empty picked your friends
in still picture nope nope
yes
look who reads books ah yeah mom I am
Gordon Freeman 3rd of July 18 2009
today I picked up her birth things at
the customs house they dug through the
trove of documents he had carried and
the rock detailing the expedition the
nature of this text ranged from quick
notes May 17th the day I was trapped
inside the object Herbert
dryly States recovered Daniel after one
hour of entrapment this confused me
greatly I was suffocating within minutes
how could I have lasted an hour in I can
see leading the peculiar text Herbert
stay his facial done without judgment
Daniel he bastard but suddenly I could
read frustration into his text he pushed
his men to invade the underground tomb
era in a buzzard view which seems to
have his account confused it and greatly
aah okay all right
oh is this where Daniel slept oh I'm so
tired
Daniel what still having nightmares whoa
yeah I can't shake Alexander video visit
Daniel in his sleep put a stop to them
you'll see ah yeah creepy old guy
right don't this set me your cockroach
you don't piss yeah yeah that's right
run away
here Oh aha I got it I know I know
[ __ ] hooker Cong Cong Cong crunch no
warning let it be what was you lie 1839
it's done the orb is assembled I was
awakened by an exhausting nightmare
shaking and sweating I retired to the
drawing room and a cup of tea the relic
pieces lay spread across the table as
I'd left them but the ancient stone
relic now rests on my table itself
uh-huh oh no no no no no I mean yeah I
fight you get out here shucks yeah you
don't know
hahaha ah hello oh hello there
and your buddy hello I try goodbye walk
away walk away
Hey
haha oh you could use that door but you
didn't feel like just using this door
you had to break it down
right oh I gotta stop this here thanks
again for watching guys and stay tuned
for part 7 of let's play amnesia the
Dark Descent where I punch more bad guys
in the face